[Música]
r
o software oficial confessou
oh
participante
wisner aparece como um disco
[Música]
chamado multi fish mesmo como é isso
esta pergunta que você joga
[Música]
Y
betis
[Música]
na cama
o brilho
que tal
uma diminuição de
consistente
[Música]
devido a transferência
chegar a este ponto acima aqui
prática de bicicleta
levar ao balcão produto diferente
meu conselho
estagnado
nós queremos dizer
e desafetos
[Música]
d
normal
[Música]
quando primeiro
a direita 4
e por que
[Música]
e provocar de outra forma
quem de todas as formas todas as máquinas
também pressionando contra o sapato
[Música]
emprestar primeiro
estes continuam dentro
[Música]
no prisma
para satisfazer com grandes espíritos
nunca acaba aqui eu continuo
você
[Música]
ponto
primeiro, mas esta equipe
e para pesquisar
[Música]
e essa parte de abertura
equipe de busca
esta parte
Y
[Música]
estar neste peso de frente que carregamos
nós
estender três anos
30 mil vezes com sua música
pequena
Isso é longo
[Música]
isso
e
[Música]
e ponto
e logo e logo